after eight months of not knowing what
the hell is going on it seems like we
finally have an update on the device
situation it's all but been confirmed
that he'll no longer be playing for nip
and that he's shopping for a new team
but how the hell did we get here and
when we'll be able to see one of csgo's
greatest talents play again
[Music]
okay so in case you somehow missed all
this back in april of 2021 device turned
the cs world upside down when he left
astralis to join ninjas in pajamas this
was after five plus years of him playing
on what is likely the greatest roster to
ever touch the game they won four majors
together and god knows how many other
tournaments and device seemingly just
walked away uh well obviously nikolai i
know that you have
you have made up your decision and
i respect you fully and i'm i'm gonna
start crying now because it's actually
quite emotional
now despite the original endless
speculation on why device would leave
his brothers behind he would go on to
give a much more reasonable explanation
as we all know the pandemic caused a lot
of travel related issues over the years
and at that time device was living in
sweden astralis was and still is based
out of denmark making traveling back and
forth a nightmare for device and at the
time device also had this to say the
boys will always be like family to me
but this covet era has left me thinking
a lot or do i see myself when it all
goes back to normal on top of nip being
based out of sweden device also
commented on the fact that nip has great
resources for handling mental health
issues which is something that he's
publicly struggled with for years now
and that is something that will come up
again in this story fast forward to
device actually playing for nip things
went pretty well sure the results were a
mixed bag but it was a very young team
and all things considered they had some
solid moments together as device wraps
back around ct smoke fades jacks oh now
dead two one more oh my god four kills
on the play and ninjas in the game
unfortunately shortly after the
stockholm major things would change the
promise that the team once showed would
take a turn for the worse in december of
2021 device would be placed on medical
leave and we would soon learn that it
was due to his ongoing struggles with
mental health nip would have to continue
without their veteran star opera while
he worked hard on getting himself back
to a place where he felt comfortable he
could play again all device asked for
was the time and space to do so since
the new year things have been mostly
quiet on all fronts there have been
rumors and speculations including a ton
about device going back to astralis for
the most part the last seven months
we've got nothing about csgo's most
decorated player until now to start nip
ceo stated that devices transferred from
astralis was one of the most expensive
in cs go history and well we've seen
reports between the ranges of 700 000
and a million us dollars which would
definitely make that true but what's
more important is what we learned from
nip's current igl campus he said that
device will not be playing with nip at
the upcoming rio major and likely won't
be playing with the team anytime soon
now this coincides with the esport
outlet jackson's reports that device has
been shopping around for a new team and
nip has been posting him up for six
figures and for what it's worth device
has been ripping face it recently which
makes his comeback seem all the more
likely that being said we still might
have some issues to start off device is
one expensive lad and it's hard to think
about what team is going to shell out
that much money for him unless the
six-figure report we heard is on the
lower end but nip likely don't want to
lose any more money so i don't see his
bio being too cheap and to make matters
worse
right now
no team really needs an opera a lot of
the young talents in csgo right now are
operas players like municy and dexter
are currently the bells of the ball and
it doesn't seem like a big team is in a
rush to pick up an expensive opera like
device who hasn't played in over seven
months except maybe astralis fans have
been dying to see device back in the
black and red so they can pretend that
this was all just one big bad dream and
to be fair to a lot of people device
will always be an astralis player but as
we all know astralis don't love
exorbitant buyouts and it would be
insane to see them pay that much
money for a player that they just sold
so what now okay well here are some of
the scenarios i personally see playing
out the most unlikely being that device
goes back to nip it's not impossible but
i'm pretty sure that that ship has
sailed as perfect as the storyline would
seem i don't see the prodigal son
returning back to astralis either that's
almost more implausible i don't know
where the hell they would get that money
from and even if they did that would be
an insane business move there are teams
outside the top tier and outside of
europe who might have the cash to pick
up device but when he left he was one of
the best players in the world i don't
think he'd be satisfied spending the
next few years trying to carry a
mid-team even though some people argue
that's what he was doing with nip
speaking of nip if they really wanted to
they could probably cut his price down
if they just wanted to get rid of him
but there's nothing that seems to compel
them to do that from a business
standpoint so what does all this mean
well we basically now live in a world
where we could see device just stuck
waiting out his contract but if we know
anything about device's career it's been
full of twists and turns so i doubt this
is the last we'll hear about the
situation and be sure that we will
update you as soon as we find out more
man
good good player that device guy good
player i'd love to see him play again
he's a good guy good player
just want to see the boy play again
um
i don't know i don't know i don't really
care about astralis